en hommage à votre qu on va faire une
interview au slip sur la tête braley là
celui dont la forme
en ce moment il est particulièrement
stressée
mais qu'elle était du côté france d'en
bas at on toujours bon est-ce que c'est
agréable à porter pardon maman
pourquoi est ce que allah jean-paul ils
en ont pas parce que c
est ce que vous pensez michael que le
monde irait mieux si tout le monde avait
un type sur la tête je pense que le
monde irait mieux si les gens vais le
porter à l'envers comme une cascade de
john d'accord super s'avère compliqué
là-bas et émotion maintenant elle le
sera pas dans un autre
club il faut éviter de me poser des
questions je suis capable de donner du
sens à mes réponses parce qu'en ce
moment j'ai l'impression d'avoir une
certaine sorte de fonctions sociales
est un peu je me la contrat et vous
gérez votre film est très très
libertaires très très imprégnée de
l'esprit on a l'impression un petit
pansement quand même que c'est
l'apocalypse à un télé il ya que des
émissions de classement comme s'il
fallait tout bien rangée avant que ce
soir mag aidons donc voila c'était un
petit peu histoire de dire merde comme
on est sûr service public on va faire
des questions qui peut plus intelligente
et pensez vous comme nietzsche que ce
qui ne vous tue pas vous rend plus fort
ça c'est kyo qu'il a dit
le groupe de rock qui
pensez vous comme un vrai mâle roux que
le but d'une vie c'est de transformer
son expérience en conscience oui
on a pris une interview avec vincent et
laurent le journaliste lui a demandé
s'il y avait un sens et vincent répondu
on aimerait l'autre mais non
justement
on amène la dernière question la merde
quoi t'as pas ce sixième sens avec les
fringues
c'est à cause de
la censure
est vide vincent oui bon c'est vous
comme benjamin castaldi un pardon
enfin tout ça mais en quoi est il faut
taper 1 si tu veux
thierry sorte que ce soit fini par nous
ses résultats et fait toujours il sait
pourquoi
mais je sais plus pourquoi je suis venu
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de nos
latitudes abonnez vous il m'était
impossible eux